[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala nos acompaña está fría
mañana bogotana de jueves en mar porque
le digo frío porque también se está
acercando el invierno en el hemisferio
norte y con él las enfermedades
respiratorias Lamentablemente si
Lamentablemente Raúl Aunque aquí en
Bogotá sabemos que el invierno es
bastante
como decías no y del frío que viene pues
viene de la mano de muchas infecciones
respiratorias enfermedades no solo el
Kobe 19 también otras y de hecho algunos
ya lo están bautizando como triple demia
una pandemia realmente se nos da bien
encontrar nombres bien alarmantes para
este tipo de cosas pero para
precisamente entender los detalles y
quizás no asustarnos tanto estamos con
Carlos Eduardo Pérez médico infectólogo
de la Universidad Nacional de Colombia
de doctor Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta mañana de jueves
cuéntenos A qué se refiere
específicamente Este término de
tripledemia
Hola amor Buenos días una de las cosas
que digamos que ese concepto es mucho
más para entender que son tres
enfermedades respiratorias pero no son
tres pandemias son enfermedades
respiratorias el virus de la influenza
el virus en sitial respiratorio del Kobe
19 en estas épocas de invierno en el
hemisferio norte que son enfermedades
respiratorias Se incrementa el número de
casos no es que son tres epidemias
simplemente la conjunción de estos virus
respiratorios que ya conocemos que se
transmiten en las comunidades en épocas
de invierno y que causan más
enfermedades y estancias hospitalarias
visitas médicas hospitalización o
incluso complicaciones
doctor los saludo un muy buena mañana de
jueves en términos de covid 19 sabemos
que las novedades suelen ser pocas y
también las novedades suelen ser épocas
complejas las navidades Mejor dicho no
las novedades eh qué podemos esperar
la
una de las cosas es que en esta época de
invierno pues ahí incremento de las
infecciones respiratorias Es el cambio
climático obviamente afecta el sistema
respiratorio hace que sea más propensa
las infecciones virales Además de eso
pues en las situaciones de invierno no
hay tanta exposición al aire libre se
deben haber más concentraciones y
aglomeraciones y personas que tengan
síntomas respiratorios pueden contagiar
además de eso recordemos que ha habido
una reducción en las tasas de vacunación
es necesario entender que nuestra
vacunación tiene que tener menos dos
refuerzos eso no lo cumple la mayoría de
la gente y eso ha hecho que
estas enfermedades en esta época sean
una amenaza y el coip probablemente
tenga unos repuntes que es lo que
estamos viendo en el centro de Europa en
Estados Unidos con la variante bb1
doctor en Más allá del hemisferio norte
porque América Latina es muy amplia y
está triple de mía es un término
importado no también de Estados Unidos o
de Europa qué podemos esperar aquí como
decíamos en Bogotá hace una frío
constante Pero tenemos zonas tropicales
tenemos incluso zonas en el hemisferio
sur que ya han pasado por un primer
invierno y que al contrario ahora se
dirigen hacia épocas más cálidas que nos
espera para la región latinoamericana en
la región es muy importante determinar
que nosotros no nos guiamos prestaciones
pero sí por los periodos de lluvias y
son muy importantes los periodos de
lluvias que llevan a incrementos que
llamamos picos respiratorios que
generalmente son dos veces al año hemos
visto en todas las regiones este
incremento del fenómeno atmosférico más
llamado de la niña que es un incremento
de las lluvias en donde estos picos
respiratorios han llevado colapsos a
varios países
hospitales en varios sitios de la región
es decir que estas enfermedades
respiratorias en las épocas de lluvia
también son un problema para el cono Sur
muy importante que requieren toda la
atención de las medidas de salud y sobre
vacunar de lo que tenemos vacuna tenemos
vacuna de Kobe tenemos vacuna influenza
hay muy buenas noticias porque ya hay
una vacuna que está cerca a probar de
virus sin citar respiratorio Entonces
tenemos que actuar y sobre todo vacunar
de lo que tenemos para prevenir esas
infecciones en la región doctor ante
todo esto vale la pena retomar a las
medidas de distanciamiento o uso de
tapabocas por ejemplo
digamos que las medidas de de
aislamiento son interesantes e
importantes de mantener cuando una
persona tenga síntomas respiratorios
aquí es muy importante entender que el
tapabocas o la mascarilla es importante
cuando yo tengo síntomas respiratorios
para ponerme en contacto y lo mismo si
tengo síntomas respiratorios y tengo
posibilidad de hacer el aislamiento en
mi hogar pues es la forma como podemos
controlar la diseminación de los
infecciones respiratorias también el
lavado de manos es fundamental lavarse
las manos usando un cobre ocas es la
herramienta para la prevención no
hacerlo así solo usarlos tapado casi
lavarse las manos no sirve para
absolutamente nada pero digamos que
situaciones de confinamiento como vimos
hace un par de años no va a suceder
porque ya tenemos vacunas un mensaje
Raúl y mar es que tenemos que vacunarnos
contra influenza que hay vacuna
disponible contra Kobe que necesitamos
un refuerzo y esperemos que en un
próximo año podamos vacunarnos paralelos
claro no definitivamente hemos aprendido
mucho de la pandemia de Kobe 19 y esos
aprendizajes Más allá de los
aislamientos de las cuarentenas los
podemos traer al resto de enfermedades
queremos hacerle una última pregunta Y
es que a veces las gripes del resfriado
lo tenemos asociado algo que es poco
grave no enfermedades leves sin embargo
sobre los sistemas de salud o sobre
grupos determinados de población
realmente hay riesgos más grandes
desde luego lo que hemos aprendido de la
pandemia es que por ejemplo en Kobe
tenemos el llamado long covid en este
momento y en mi misma práctica tenemos
un incremento impresionante casos de
enfermedades neurológicas relacionadas
al poscoy y estamos viendo
complicaciones nosotros todavía no
sabemos Qué ha pasado con la enfermedad
y para analizar la enfermedad pensando
que simplemente una enfermedad
respiratoria es muy pobre todavía no
sabemos las complicaciones a cinco o
diez años faltará mucho en la historia
para saber qué complicaciones hubo pero
definitivamente el covid prolongado es
un problema que tenemos que enfrentar
también hay enfermedades relacionadas
con secuelas respiratorias de otros
virus respiratorios y por eso es que
tenemos que mantener las medidas de la
higiene de manos cuando ella síntomas
respiratorios usar un tapabocas
vacunarse reforzarse la vacuna de Kobe y
sobre todo estar pendiente de estas
épocas de Lluvia de tener abrigo y de
consultar prontamente al médico si hay
complicaciones
doctor como siempre Muchísimas gracias
por su información y todas estas
recomendaciones de cara al invierno no
al hemisferio norte y también los
inviernos que nosotros podemos tener
aquí en el sur mar como siempre También
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información por acompañarnos siempre en
temas de salud nos vemos mañana